here is my first free tip for the World Cup in guitar
in this video.
we're going to run through the groups one by one
and look at our favourite selections
for either a group winner,
a group to qualify
or 2 teams to qualify from the same group.
starting off in Group A,
the host Qatar,
Ecuador Senegal
and the Netherlands
importantly for Senegal,
manny does make the World Cup squad
but we don't know the extent of his injury
and if he'll be starting the first few games
under Louis Van Hale.
Netherlands are on a 15 match unbeaten run.
gonna take them to win the group here
as I just think they have too much quality
for the other 3 teams in the group.
group B and England coming to this one
after getting relegated against Hungary,
Italy and Germany in the Nations League
got to the Euro final.
but they did have a favorable route
same with the last World Cup.
the group is probably the easiest they could have got.
while I wouldn't back them to get very far
in the tournament.
they should win this group fairly easily.
group C, Argentina,
Saudi Arabia,
Mexico and Poland
and Messi lead Argentina to World Cup glory
and what would be his thousand professional match.
Argentina are currently on a 35 match unbeaten run
and we're gonna take them to win the group here.
group D includes France,
the reigning champions
and the dark horses of the last Euros,
Denmark expect France to win this group,
but you can't count on them.
they usually drop points against smaller teams.
best way to play this one
for group D,
we're gonna take France and Denmark
to both qualify from the group.
group E could arguably be one of the toughest groups
in the World Cup.
Japan are a lot of people's dark horses
in this tournament.
unfortunately for them,
they're in a group
with the 2010 champion
Spain and the 2014 champions Germany.
while I rate Japan a lot.
I don't think
they'll have enough to get past either of these 2.
so the pick for Group E is going to be Spain
and Germany both to qualify from the group.
Belgium's golden generation
are yet to win a major trophy.
this could be one of their last chances here.
with the aging squad they have.
Belgium are renowned for bullying small teams
and getting the results against them,
but then struggling against the bigger teams.
if we're gonna take Belgium to win the group,
only 2 defeats
in the last 42 competitive matches
for Brazil, they went unbeaten in qualifying,
winning 14 games,
drawing 3 and losing 0.
the favourites for the whole competition,
and rightly so
with the squad they have
and the conditions and the heat,
it probably will favour South American sides
compared to European teams
too tough to call
Serbia and Switzerland,
who's gonna make it out of the group.
so the pick
here for Group G
is Brazil to win the group.
expect this World Cup to be Cristiano Ronaldo's last.
have excellent depth with their squad as well.
main competitors in their group are Uruguay.
brought in a new manager during qualifiers
and have since had an incredible run of form.
for this one,
we're gonna take Portugal and Uruguay
both to qualify
from the group.
there are my 8 picks for the group stages initially.
make sure to drop a follow
so you don't miss any
free tips on the World Cup
free Telegram group link
will be posted on TikTok
in the bio at 1000 followers.